we've been talking about arithmetic and
algebra and we'll be trying to flex our
muscles on this because this is kind of
your bread and butter this is your this
is it an Australian Open fan who watch
the Australian Open over summer yeah
okay all right so I'm kind of a bit of a
nut so this is to give you a tennis
metaphor this is the forehand of the
advance and extension one course okay
you're going to be doing this constantly
all the time it's the kind of thing you
don't want to think about how do I do
this all right you're gonna be doing
this all the time you want this to be
kind of effortless the word we use in
the mathematics syllabus for this is
fluency right when you're fluent in a
language you don't think you have to
don't have to look up a phrase book or a
dictionary to think about what words are
gonna come out of your mouth you just
you know what these words mean you know
what I'm saying right now hopefully
you're like these words are English this
is our language I'm fluent in this is a
skill or a set of skills that you want
to be fluent in because there's other
things other real problems that you want
to focus on yes it slides well done
either real proof problems you want to
focus on and you don't want to have
space in your brain taken up by having
to you know like I don't know how I'm
not very comfortable with this I've got
to think really hard about how to do
this and then there's this whole other
problem I gotta solve okay this part you
want to do automatically now with
quadratic expressions and equations we
already know just imagine right what's
the difference between an equation and
an expression it's in the word itself an
equation has an thank you very much so
this is something equal to something
else when we're working with the spread
expressions sometimes we introduce an
equal sign but that's just so that we
can simplify work with it interact with
it these guys come with the equal signs
right out the box okay now for that
reason we're going to teach you about or
revise you over three different skills
today but one of them's about
expressions and two of them about
equations and not knowing the difference
causes problems so that's why I'm
highlighting it for you now okay now the
first one which you're going to be
reasonably familiar starts with an F
when you have a quadratic expression
like x squared plus 5x plus 6 you can do
what to it what's the instinctive thing
to do factorize thank you very much
you can factorize an expression okay
and that's pretty much all you can do
you can't solve an expression can you
because it's not equal to anything right
so you're not going to get our X is
equal to this if it's an expression like
I said x squared plus 5x plus 6 before X
can be absolutely anything you like it's
not it doesn't have to equal anything
okay now with equations there are two
other skills that are related to this
but you've probably kind of mix them
together in your brain okay when you've
got like not something like this but if
you've got some weird awkward quadratic
formula like say this okay you can still
work with this sorry expression you can
still work with this you can still solve
this but you're not gonna try to
factorize are you what are you gonna do
what skill did you learn last year don't
help you you could say yeah you're gonna
get you are gonna get two answers out of
this I hope something or something else
what mechanism will be is to get those
two answers yeah we're going to use that
so close I think I know what you mean
but it's not quite we've got a quadratic
equation that is one starts with an F
again what is it it's the formula right
so we call it the quadratic formula yeah
yeah in fact let's jot this down so we
can remember this right the quadratic
formula is to be awkward x equals I'll
give you a clue it's got a it's a big
fraction right is anywhere even what the
big fraction starts with you go ahead
don't toss the whole thing tell me how
it starts
very good and then because as was
pointed out there are two solutions
right this next bit says plus or minus
indicating one of the solutions you'll
get by adding and one of the solutions
you get by subtracting okay what am i
adding an x' and subtractive it's a big
square root sign and then hmm what's
under here very good okay b squared
minus 4ac okay it's sort of kicking in
that's the numerator it's a bit big and
gross thankfully the denominator is not
big and gross it's just to eight cool so
this is the quadratic formula and you've
encountered it before it took a bit of
time for us to remember it so maybe this
is the whole point of jogging your
memory on this
the quadratic formula is something you
can only do to an equation not an
expression right because what you're
going to get out of the quadratic
formula is X is equal to a couple of
different values right when you have a
look at this guy X doesn't equal to like
only two values X can be anything you
like you can choose it's a variable
right so the quadratic formula is
something you only do to these equations
how many of you know and I'm expecting
some of you but probably not all of you
how many of you know where the quadratic
formula comes from like this didn't just
come in a box people just discovered it
one day there was something we knew how
to do to get us there does anyone know
yes okay let's write this down x squared
plus BX plus C what's you're stating
here is the general equation of a
quadratic sorry the general form of a
quadratic equation right where a B and C
could be anything you like yeah now
there's something that we do and again
if you don't know it's totally okay
that's what I'm trying to get a sense of
there's something we can do to this that
actually turns it into that so you won't
know what that is it's a bit awkward
yeah go ahead
okay can you say that one more time just
louder so the entire room can hear you
solve this the way you solve a perfect
square so just so we all know what
you're talking about
this is a perfect square this guy here
right it's something squared there's
nothing else so it's it's perfect
there's no extra bits hanging on so we
somehow want to turn something looks
like this into something it looks like
that it's just go straight path it's
fine it's fine
it's okay I add it that's that's what I
do now this process this process it has
a name turning this which looks gross
and messy into this which looks nice and
neat and maybe this rings a bell this
process is called completing the square
completing the square okay now these
three one two and three this is what
we're going to good money spend the bulk
of our time on okay so today because
even though we have three periods
there's a lots of cover here right like
these are some big massive ideas so this
is where we're going
make a little sub hang for me which is
factorizing okay
now let's begin with this example that I
actually already wrote on the board x
squared plus 5x plus 6 it's a really
nice easy one to deal with x squared
plus 5x plus 6 now this is just an
expression in a row there's no equal
sign so we could factorize it right now
if I factorize I'm just gonna put this
underneath factorizing as the name
suggests is writing something in terms
of its factors right with numbers like
say 18 you can break up 18 into factors
like 2 times 9 those are two factors
that multiply together well 3 times 6
right so there are these two factors
that multiply together to give this now
we've actually spent like a good couple
of years on this can anyone tell me
right away what the factors are you go
ahead it's 3 & 2 okay now I'm going to
use those numbers 3 & 2 okay those are
the two numbers I'm going to think of
but I noticed that they're kind of part
of a factor 3 & 2 I'm not the factors of
that because 3 times 2 is not x squared
there's no X's in it right so 3 & 2 of
the factors of 6 but I can use those
numbers what's missing yeah the x's
right so X plus 2 that's the factor X
plus 3 that's the other factor are you
with me okay so in fact that's probably
worth writing down this whole thing is a
factor and this whole thing
is the factor but of course we've
thought of two and three because they
were the important parts of it right now
you push on that how did you think of
two and three where two two and three
come from so I know you know the answer
because you gave you the numbers someone
else told me I think we know right yeah
go ahead
two times three gives you six and two
plus three gives you five so these are
the numbers that we're focusing on here
yeah we want numbers that add up to this
multiply to that okay
are you happy so far yep okay good now
this is with an expression right if I
change this into equation so this is a
whole different question now this is a
different question okay do you see that
factorizing is a step we can use to get
us toward the solution right it's it's
not something you do to get to the
answer right away it's like an
intermediate step
okay so factorizing is something you do
to expression and then you can go ahead
and subsequently solve so what would I
get at the bottom here again like we
accepted before there will be two
solutions it's someone who hasn't
suggested an answer yet thank you though
what do you think okay are you happy
with that negative 3 or negative 2 by
the way
total minor pedantic point but these are
negative signs yeah - is an operation
it's something you do between two
different numbers and negatives is in
equality it's an adjective there's no
like pair of numbers here it's just
negative 3 itself okay